In den USA geht eine neuartige “Zombie-Krankheit”
herum: Die Nervenkrankheit “Chronic Wasting
Disease” (CWD) betrifft bisher vor allem
Elche, Rehe und Hirsche in mindestens 24 US-Bundesstaaten.
Und die Symptome der erkrankten Tiere erinnern
wirklich sehr an Zombies.
Sie haben ihren Körper nicht mehr unter Kontrolle,
werden aggressiv und verlieren ihre Angst
vor Menschen.
Jetzt schlagen US-Fachleute Alarm.
Demnach kann wohl nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
werden, dass diese “Zombie”-Nervenkrankheit
auch auf Menschen übertragbar ist.
Eine Behandlung oder Impfstoffe jedoch gibt
es bisher nicht.
Sind wir ihr wehrlos ausgeliefert?
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos - abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Und vielen Dank für diesen Themenvorschlag,
den sich wirklich wahnsinnig viele von Euch
über unsere WhatsApp Comunnity gewünscht
haben!
Den Link gibt es in der Infobox und am Ende
des Videos.
Die Lage in den USA ist laut der US-Bundesbehörde
“Center of Disease Control and Prevention”
(CDC) angespannt.
Die Fachleute dort beschäftigen sich mit
ansteckenden Krankheiten und haben jetzt eine
alarmierende Warnung herausgegeben.
Es geht um die sogenannte “Chronic Wasting
Disease” (CWD) - auch als Zombie-Hirsch-Krankheit
bezeichnet.
Und diesen Namen trägt sie völlig zurecht,
denn die erkrankten Tiere erinnern tatsächlich
an Untote.
Sie nehmen stark ab, haben ihren Körper kaum
noch unter Kontrolle und sabbern.
Zudem verlieren sie ihre Angst vor Menschen
und werden dafür immer aggressiver.
Vergleichbar ist CWD auch mit Rinderwahn (BSE)
und Scrapie bei Schafen, denn auch hierbei
handelt es sich um eine ansteckende Prionen-Erkrankung.
Diese entstehen, wenn sich ein bestimmtes
Zelloberflächen-Protein im Gehirn - das sogenannte
Prion-Protein - fehlerhaft faltet.
Die Krankheit greift also das zentrale Nervensystem
an.
Übertragen wird die Zombie-Krankheit wohl
über Blut, Urin, Speichel oder Kot.
Klar ist jedenfalls, dass sich CWD gerade
rasant in den USA ausbreitet.
Bislang sind nur Tiere wie Elche und Hirsche
unter den Opfern.
Das jedoch in mindestens 24 US-Staaten und
in zwei kanadischen Provinzen.
Fälle, in denen CWD auch auf Haustiere oder
gar Menschen übertragen wurde, sind bisher
nicht bekannt.
Das galt bisher auch als eher unwahrscheinlich.
Doch das hat sich jetzt wohl geändert.
Mittlerweile kann wohl nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
werden, dass sich die Krankheit auch auf Menschen
übertragen könnte.
Davor warnt jetzt zumindest der US-Forscher
Michael Osterholm, der als Experte für Infektionskrankheiten
gilt: "Es ist wahrscheinlich, dass Fälle
von CWD beim Menschen in den kommenden Jahren
dokumentiert werden, die mit dem Verzehr von
kontaminiertem Fleisch in Verbindung stehen”.
Dass es derzeit noch keine Beweise für Infektionen
beim Menschen gibt, liegt seiner Ansicht nach
an dem verzögerten Auftreten der Krankheiten.
Dazu der Wissenschaftler: “Wir können nicht
auf die ersten Fälle warten."
Auch die US-Behörde CDC ordnet die Krankheit
als ernsthafte Bedrohung ein.
Auf der Website heißt es: “Bislang hat
es keine Fälle einer CWD-Infektion bei Menschen
gegeben.
Einige Studien an Tieren legen jedoch nahe,
dass es ein Risiko für bestimmte nicht-menschliche
Primaten-Arten wie beispielsweise Affen gibt,
die in Kontakt mit Körperflüssigkeiten von
infizierten Rehen oder Elchen kommen oder
das Fleisch von denjenigen Tieren essen, die
mit CWD infiziert sind.“
Die Studien deuten demnach aber darauf hin,
dass auch Menschen gefährdet sein könnten.
Das deutsche Friedrich-Loeffler-Institut schrieb
dazu 2016 auf seiner Website: “Derzeit kann
eine Übertragung auf den Menschen nicht gänzlich
ausgeschlossen werden, dennoch scheint diese
Gefahr, ähnlich wie bei Scrapie, sehr gering
zu sein.“
Demnach legen Studien nahe, dass es eine erhebliche
Spezies-Barriere bei der Übertragung von
CWD auf Menschen gibt.
Erste Fälle von CWD wurden übrigens schon
1967 bekannt.
Und zwar bei Maultierhirschen in Colorado.
Seitdem wurde die Krankheit aus Südkorea,
mindestens 24 US-Staaten und zwei kanadischen
Provinzen gemeldet.
Im April 2016 dann das erste Mal außerhalb
von Nordamerika und Südkorea - und zwar in
Europa; bei einem Rentier in Norwegen.
Und so beobachtet man die Erkrankung dort
ganz genau.
Mittlerweile wurde CWD bei 19 Rentieren, vier
Elchen und einem Rothirsch in Norwegen festgestellt
und deswegen mehr als 1.400 Rentiere alleine
in der Region Nordfjella erschossen.
Mehr als 70.000 Tiere wurden untersucht.
Dazu das norwegische Landwirtschaftsministerium:
“Norwegen hat große Anstrengungen unternommen,
um CWD auszumerzen, aber wir wissen nicht,
ob wir es schon geschafft haben.”
Ausgeschlossen werden kann keinesfalls, dass
CWD auch nach Deutschland gelangt.
Möglich ist dies zum einen über den natürlichen
Weg, also über Tiere, die eingeschleppt werden.
Aber auch Urlauber oder Jäger könnten dazu
beitragen, dass die Krankheit auch zu uns
erreicht.
Klar ist aber: Um den Kampf gegen die Krankheit
wirklich aufzunehmen, muss wohl noch jahrelang
intensiv geforscht werden.
Zum derzeitigen Zeitpunkt haben wir jedenfalls
nichts gegen die Krankheit in der Hand: weder
medizinische Behandlungen noch Impfungen.
Aktuell: Nach Zyklon "Idai": Südosten Afrikas
droht Cholera-Epidemie Draufklicken und anschauen,
denn da sieht man gut, wie schnell Epidemien
außer Kontrolle geraten.
Ansonsten Bis dann, bleibt dran!